I mean the reason i got to know david
axelrod was from last September's oh
we've had a series of conversations as
he came over this week he ran two
campaigns for President Obama about what
they thought was the biggest issue in
America which is very similar to the
issue we face here which is the growing
gap between the richest and everybody
else and the way the country the way so
many people feel they don't get a fair
crack of the whip and so what tracted me
to him was he'd run two campaigns on
those subjects and then we had a series
of conversations about how we address
this issue how we how we explain the
huge trends are are which are pushing
countries in this direction and how
important it is that you have a
government that says actually we're
going to do something about it and
that's what labor is obviously saying in
this campaign and that's the action and
labour government will take so so that's
the role that he's playing in a way he's
providing some of the expertise he had
in making similar arguments to the
arguments that we're making but also
unfortunately perhaps in this television
age is also talking about the candidate
and the presentation we hear he's given
you a bit of a makeover male presenter
in television for seeing the result is
extraordinary that people write a lot of
nonsense I mean all this is kind of very
very wide of the mark we've talked about
ideas and that's and that's absolutely
what we've what we've been talking at
this makeover stuff is nonsense wait
let's talk about colors and I mean I was
thinking about look we matching guys I
think about what I can share Thomas you
that I have never taught them about the
the color of my time